ميداليا قرات هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
قواتها قصفت في الساعات الماضيه اكثر من
10 مناطق لتمركز القوات الروسيه داخل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه
ان القوات الروسيه في المقابل نفذت امس
سبعه غارات جويه واكثر من 70 رشقه صاروخيه
مستهدفه بشكل اساسي البنيه التحتيه
المدنيه في مقاطعه الاوكرانيه
في صفوف المدنيين
وفي مقاطع
مراسل الجزيره بسماع يدويا انفجارات ضخمه
وقال ان قصها المكثفه ليتواصل بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والروسيه على ضفتين نهر
الروس قصفوا الضفه اليمنى من المقاطعه
اكثر من 100 مره خلال اليوم الوطني
مستخدمين المدفعيه الثقيله وقذفات الهون
كما اعلن حاكم مقاطعه
الكساندر ستروخ عند القوات الروسيه كشفت
قصفها للمقاطعه في الساعات الاربعه
والعشرين الماضيه
الثالثه تدمير 64 مبنى سكنيا ومنشات
البنيه التحتيه المدنيه وقالت السلطه
الاوكرانيه في المقاطعه ان الروس يرسلون
مزيدا من التعزيزات باتجاه مواقع سيطرتهم
اللاسيه الجنوبي
خلص سلطات الروسيه المدنيه
استهدف احياء سكنيه عذاب اكثر من 200
قطيفه والحق اضرار الماديه بعدد من
المباني السكنيه ومرافق البنيه التحتيه في
المنطقه
فدى مراسل الجزيره ان عدد ضحايا القذف
الروسي الذي استهدف مبنى سكنيا في مدينه
الدنبر قبل ثلاثه ايام ارتفع الى 44 قتيلا
بعد فمراسل الجزيره ان هيئه الطوارئ
الاوكرانيه تعلن عزمها ايقاف عمليات البحث
عن ناجين اعتبارا من يوم غدا من جانبها
قالت هيئه الطوارئ الاوكرانيه ان نحو 20
شخصا ما يزالون تحت الانقاذ وفرص انقاذهم
باتت معدومه وكان الكرملين قد نفى
مسؤوليتك قوته عن الهجوم وحمل المضادات
الاكرانيه المسؤوله
تعرضت اليوم لقصه صاروخيه من الجيش الروسي
المتمرز في مقاطعه
انا من دينيبرو مراسل الجزيره عمر الحاج
عمر وقد طلعنا معك في الساعه الماضيه على
جهود الانقاذ في المبنى الذي السكن الذي
يقصف قبل ثلاثه ايام يبدو ان الجهود هذه
توقفت له
نعم زين الجهود ستتوقف وفقا لهيئه الطوارئ
عند عند يوم غد اعتبارا من يوم غد وسيعتبر
من بقي تحت الانقاذ في اعداد الموتى كما
ذكرتم في الخبر فان عدد الضحايا ارتفع الى
44 شخصا قبل قليل شاهدنا اخراج جثث لعائله
مكونه فيها ثلاثه اطفال كانوا من بين
القتلى وهذا ما رفع عدد الضحك كما تشاهدون
من خلف فان وثيره عمليات همم البحث
تراجعت كثيرا مقارنه بالساعات همم الماضيه
وهذا مصداقا لما قالته هيئه الطوارئ درجات
الحراره التي تصل ليلا الى سالب عشره
وسالب 12 درجه اضافه الى
مروري اكثر على
مرور اكثر من 72 ساعه همم حتى الان عن هذا
الاستهداف هو ما يقلل الامل في وجود احياء
بين من بقي عالقين والذين يبلغ عددهم على
حتى تصريح وفق خريطه تصريحات رسميه
25 شخصا السلطات الاوكرانيه جددت مره
ثانيه مره ثانيه اللون على القوات الروسيه
واكد انها هي المسؤوله عن استهداف هذا
المبنى وعن ما تسميها بالجريمه
بحق المدنيين وان الصاروخ الذي
سقط على هذا المبنى كان يستهدف محطه توليد
الطاقه القريبه من البناء ولكنه اخطا
الهدف كذلك الامر في مناطق متفرقه من
مقاطعه دينيفره وكما قال حاكم والمقاطعه
فان مدينه نيكولا المقابله لمدينه
انورغدار التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه
تعرضت للقصف في ساعات الصباح همم برجمات
برجمات الصواريخ اضافه للمدفعيه همم
الثقيله في المنطقه الشرقيه قبل قليل بثته
قياده العمليات الاوكرانيه صورا لما قالت
ان انها التقطت بطائرات الاستطلاع العائده
اللواء خمسه واربعين العام في مدينه سوريا
وتظهر الصور استهداف في مجموعه من قوات
فقالت انها قطره 25 عنصرا منهم في هذا
السادات مدينه باخمد ايضا تجددت فيها
محاولات التقدم الروسيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه قالت انها تتصدى لمحاولات من
الجهه الشرقيه والغربيه اضافه الى الجهه
الجنوبيه التي هي اعنف المناطق التي تحاول
منها القوات الروسيه الولوج الى احياء
المدينه التي تقود القوات الاوكرانيه انها
ما تزال تسيطر عليها بشكل كامل قبل قليل
ايضا كان هناك اعلان عن مقتل شخصين وجرحي
عشرات همم في قصف مستهدف مناطق متفرقه من
مقاطعه اندونيس هذا ما اعلنه بابلو حاكم
المقاطعه والذي اشار الى تجدد العمليات
العسكريه في المنطقه الجنوبيه التي كانت
تشهد ركودا مقارنه مع باقي المناطق في
الفترات الماضيه طيب من الواضح ان هنالك
تصعيد في الايام الاخيره في المناطق
الجنوبيه وايضا في الجبهه الشرقيه هل ادى
ذلك وفقا في البيانات الاوكرانيه الى اي
اختلاف موازين القوى على الارض
يعني في دار نقرب الصوره هنا بتصليط الضوء
على شكل البيانات التي كانت تصدر من قياده
العمليات الاوكرانيه في الايام الاولى
لعمليه لمعارك سوريا بوجه الخصوص كانت
القوات الاوكرانيه في كل مره تقول انها
تنفي هذه الروايه وان الروايه الروسيه
عاريه عن الصحه والقوات الاوكرانيه ما
تزال موجوده ولكن بالمقارنه مع البيانات
التي صدرت امس واليوم فاننا نتحدث عن بيان
تقول فيه القوات الاوكرانيه عند العمليات
العسكريه ما تزالوا مستمر دون ان تاتي على
ذكر همم مواقع السيطره او نسبه السيطره
همم في مدينه سوليدر بالتحديد طبعا هذا
الغموض وحتى الان السرقه همم الاحداث ربما
يعود لحده المعارك هناك وتضارب بعض
التصريحات الاخرانيه فمنها قياده الاركان
حتى يوم امس تقول من المدينه تحت سيطره
القوات الاوكرانيه وفي ذات التوقيت كان
هناك احد قاده العمليات في مدينه سوريا
تحدث عن تغير خطوط المواجهه وان العمليات
العسكريه باتت الان خارجه الحدود الاداريه
لتعوده هيئه الارك مره اخرى في ايه بتصريح
يكذب بطريقه مباشره هذا التصريح الصادر عن
قائد العمليات وتقول ان لا تغيير على سير
عمليات هناك وان سوليدر ما تزال تحت
سيطرته القوات الاوكرانيه هذا يدل على
شراسه العمليات العسكريه هناك لان القوات
الروسيه استخدمت الكثير من تازات عسكريه
اعتمدت على خيره مقاتله هذا ما تقول له
القوات الاوكرانيه في بيانات السابقه
اضافه بعجال فداء ان القوات اوكرانيه
استبقت هذه الهجمات بان بتصليح قالت فيه
ان القوات الروسيه رفعت من عدد قواتها
العامله تحديدا في المنطقه الشرقيه الى
280 او واحده مقارنه مع 200 وثلاثين دون
ان تذكر العدد بالتحديد وهذا من عكس واقعا
على السيد العمليات العسكريه سواء في
الجبهات التي قمنا انها كانت راكده
ومارينكا وكذلك الامر في جبههسك التي كانت
المبادره للقوات الاوكرانيه الان نتحدث عن
عمليات اقرب للدفاع تصلح عنها القوات
الاوكرانيه في جبهه تحديدا في صفوف
تقول ان تقدمها الذي كان ملحوظا في الفريق
السابقه تباطها بفعل الهجمات الروسيه عمر
الحاج منمر مراسل الجزيره شكرا لك